bu
Toroslar'ın eteklerinde Muğla'nın
Seydikemer ilçesinin Seki kasabasında
doğmuş büyümüş dağlarında ormanlarda
koşmuş toplamış zıplamış bir yörük
kızının hikayesini anlatacağım size o
kişi Hacer Akyüz Ben birlikteyiz sizde
şimdi
bu kız nereden nereye neler yapmış O
Umarım Sizler de örnek olur diye
düşünüyorum
İlkokulu Fethiye'de Atatürk ilkokulu
Ortaokulu Fethiye Ortaokulunda okumuşum
o dönemde Fethiye'de orta okulda okurken
bir basketbol maçına kocamız beni seçti
takımda oynuyor Bu köyceğiz'e yarışmaya
gidiyoruz
köyceğiz'e yarışmaya giderken spor
salonu önünde ilk kez ailenden
ayrılıyorum Fethiye'den başka bir yere
gidiyorum ve spor salonunda herkesin
bütün sevginin de şortumu ya eşofmanımın
altı çıkartıp şortunu giymem geriye
şortumu sol şortla çıkmam gerekiyor
Nasıl utandım anlatamam
Nasıl heyecanlandırma mı Tamam Şöyle
türbinlerine baktım benim için önemliydi
ilk defa böyle bir şey yapıyordum
küçücük Ortaokulda
Ortaokulda fetheden çıktım da lisede
Gülhane Sağlık Meslek Lisesi'ni kazandım
Ankara'ya geldim Ankara'ya geldim
Ankara'da Gülhane Sağlık Meslek Lisesi
askeri bir okul o dönemde hemşire
yetiştiriyor Silahlı Kuvvetleri ve 1987
yılında önün da dünya orduları arası
voleybol şampiyonası yapıldı yine
seçildim dine orada altı kesmeli oldum
bu branş Voleybol nasıl keyif aldım
antrenmanlar yapıyoruz ama Ailem izin
vermiyor
Türkiye'den yaz dönemde 2012
2.987 yılında yıl süren oraya gitmem
gerekiyor Ankara'ya ama izin vermiyor
Ben anatomi dersinde bütünlemeye
bıraktım
aileme dedim ki bütün hemen var
diyemiyorum ki dünya şampiyonasına
katılacağım
Evet dünya şampiyonasına katılmak için
anatomi dersi bütünleme bırakmış ve
dünya şampiyonu sa katılıp altı kez
milli sporcu kız Burada da acele Akyüz
Evet liseden sonra bu üniversite dönemi
liseden sonra Erzurum'a mezun oldum
hemşire olarak Erzurum'a Tamam yapıldı
oraya gittim 18 yaşında babamı kaybettim
babamı kaybettikten sonra tek başına
Erzurum'da 18 yaşında göreve başladım
hiç kolay değil bir
tek başına doğuda ilk defa Muğla'dan
Ankara'dan ilk defa başka bir yere
gidiyorsun Hiç Bilmediğin Bir yere be
orada
hemşirelik yaptım hemşirelik yaparken
müthiş bir manevi keyif aldım Kaya
başladım kayak yapan yoktu abdest ipini
kayak bir gün hastanede hiç kimse yokken
ben Amirim izin vermediği için sürekli
bu tür faaliyetlere gitmem ise bir de
ebelik yapıyoruz icapçı hasta gelirse
bir hamile kadın 7'si oraya gitmemiz
gerekiyor
kafayı koyduk yapacağız O gün Kaya
gideceğiz ilk kar yağdığı O hiç
kıyamazmış karın üzerine kaymak müthiş
bir keyif ne yaptık ambulansın arkasına
bir arkadaşımla kaynakları koydum çünkü
Hastaneden çıkarken görülmem gerekiyordu
ve kaynaklarımı kaçırdım ben kendi Yürek
taksiye 100 metre soralım lan sen aldım
ve taksiye bindik ve Palandöken'de kayak
fiyat kayak yapmak üzere gittik
şu an pır pır pır o kalp sonra döndüm
tabi yine Yakalandık kayakta kıpkırmızı
bir suratkaya mı gittiniz Mesai saatinde
Evet işte sporu böyle şartlarda yaptık
çok keyif aldık
de Erzurum'da sağlık hemşire olarak
çalışırken bunun ötesinde aynı zamanda
hayalim olan sporculuk sporculuk
yapabilme bol bol milli voleybolcu
olarak gitmiş Ama bir voleybol takımı
yok orada bir voleybol takımı yok kadın
olarak oynayabileceğiniz bir voleybol
takımı yok Galatasaray'a gittim
İstanbul'da ya Erzurum'dan oraya gidip
gelmek o dönemde mümkün değil
mesleğini bırakamıyorum paraya ihtiyacım
var En sonunda orada En azından takım
Yok voleyboldan ayrı kalmayalım hak
etmek basına çıktık voleybolun ilk kadın
Hakemleri olarak Erzurum'da iplikleri
yaptık ilkleri ilk lera Hayatımız hep
etler olmalı ki bu ipler içerisinde
yine Erzurum'da beden eğitimi bölümünü
birincilikle kazandım hemşire olarak
çalışıyorum gece gündüz okula gidiyorum
ve Eğitim Bölümü kasanın beden eğitimi
bölümünde badminton badminton o zaman
Türkiye'de Yok daha yeni yeni ilk
birlikte oluşuyor daha ve bir hocamız
sayesinde bunu öğrendik ve ardından bir
baktık ki
badmintonda
da milli takıma seçilmiş iz Edirne'de
bir takım kampına çağrılmış hız
Anadolu'dan giden tek
kadınsın Bunların hepsi Ben başka bir
keyif Sadece o mu bunun dışında
badmintonun Kaya voleybol basketbol
oradan üniversiteden Ankara'ya tayin
oldum aynı zamanda Gazi Üniversitesi
Beden eğitim Bölümü'nde okuyorum ve den
eğitimi Bölümü'nde okurken oryantring
buluştuk harita Pusula ile yön bulma bir
kadın arazi tek başına ve hemşirelik
Sağlık Meslek Yüksek okulundan
öğrenciler alıp götürecek dokuz kızla
başladığımız bir süreç 90'lı yıllar var
95 li yıllar bu süreçte de tutup
bu sporu yapmaya çalışacak hem de arazi
şartları bu zor şartlarda neler yapmadık
ki o kadar çok sporcu milli takım
sporcusu olarak yurtdışına gönderdik
dünya şampiyonu Sami takımı antrenörü
olarak katıldım 2000'li yılların
başlarında o zaman Federasyonu yok
dağcılık ve İzcilik Federasyonu altında
64 federasyondan birisi olarak devam
etti ve 2006 yılında özellikle Şti
64 federasyondan birisi
antrenörlük hakemlik sporculuk ve
peşinden Eğitim Kurulu üyeliği
oryantring değil temsilciliği
yardımcıları yönetim kurulu üyeleri
yaşından de
2016-2020 bir yıllarında Türk
oryantiring Federasyonu Başkanı Bir de
Başkanlığı ekledi Bu bir Başkan bir sürü
spordan gel bir de oryantiring
Federasyonu Başkanı Ol tabii ki kadın
olarak Öncelikle ben bunu düşünmedim
yani Başkan olmayı düşünmedim ama bir
grup arkadaşımız dedi ki Evet biz seni
istiyoruz
senin yapabileceğin düşünüyoruz biz de
evet Tamam dedik
katıldık neler yapmadık ki federasyon
başkanı olarak kolay oldu mu Hayır hiç
kolay olmadı Ne ne zorluklar yaşadık bir
kadınsın 64 Federasyonu 3 federasyon
başkanı üç kadından birisi hem de
Olimpik değil branşın Türkiye'de branşın
Olimpik değilse sporda için çok zor
olimpiyatlara gidenlere verilen ücretler
olamıyorsun Milli Takımlar için milli
takım sporcuları için sporcu eğitim
merkezlerinden Olimpik merkezlerden
faydalı atamıyorsun kendi yağında
kavrulmaya çalışıyorsun aynı zamanda ve
olimpik olmadığın için ve basında
Görünürlüğü yok vatandaş sporcu o ülke
içerisinde tanıştığı O kadar değil bir
de var olma mücadelesi veriyorsun
gece gündüz 24 saat 24 saatler bile
geçmedi bize de ama bir kadın eli
değerse böyle oluyor beş yılda neler
yapmadık neler ör kısaca çok başlık
küçüksün başlıklarla özetlemek istiyorum
Milli Eğitim bakanlığı'yla çocuklarımız
dolaşalım bir protokol yaptık bir süre
eğitimler sana oryantrik etkinlikleri
sana fabrikasyon oyunları sanal
yarışmalar çevrimiçi kurslar Seminerler
bir sürü faaliyetler mi takım
sporcularına yapılan eğitimler bu sporun
yapılması için milli üronik kez hep
ilkler Ülkemizde ilk kez bir dünya
şampiyonası gençler dünya şampiyonası
organizasyonu ilk da ilk kez bir kayak
torrenting Avrupa Şampiyonası Yani bu
ipleri bir yapacak ikili üçüncüde
başkaları yapsın sürekli su ekleyelim E
şimdi bir bakıyorsun hem Akademisi yasak
üniversitede görev yapıyorsun Hem
başkansın Türkiye'nin başkanı 81'de
yetişmem gerekiyor Ben bir evli bir eşin
var bir de İki çocuk annesi hiç kolay
değil ama yapabildiğine gösterdik mi
gösterdik gösterecek miyiz Tabii ki
göstereceğiz
Ama bunları yaparken Biz son iki yıldır
pandemi proje mücadele ediyoruz
pandemi pandemi pandemi günlük vaka
sayıları bunun dışlı aşılır ölümler şu
kadar sevdiklerimizin hastalandığında
yanına gidemedik yasak ziyaret edemedik
yasak ölümler olduğu cenazesine
gidemedik yasak
Dünya bamba Bu bir yere gittik hiç kolay
değil
bunun nasıl başaracağız hep birlikte
başaracağız Nasıl yapacağız hepimizde
bir stres bir kaygı ve bir Karamsarlık
karamsar bir depresyon Cahit bundan
çıkmamız gerekiyor
oryantring Tam bu dönemde Yıldızı
Parladı pandemi de doğada yaptık biz
bunu ormanda yaptık bireysel olarak
yaptık Hep doğaya çıktık şık yasaklar
kalktım da biz hep doğada yaydık Çünkü
bizim branşınız bireysel ve doğa spor
yudu
E şimdi neden Şu dönemde böyle bir
ortamda Bunlara devam etmeyelim ki
branşınızla devam etmeyelim neden doğaya
çıkmayalım doğaya çıkmaya çalışıyoruz
bir bakıyoruz
zaten ormanlarımız gidiyor ormanlarımız
yanıyor pembeye uğraşırken bir dur bu
bulguların eden küresel ısınma iklim
değişiklikleri e şimdiden biz bunları
önüne geçmezsek Önümüzdeki dönemde çok
daha büyük sıkıntılara karşı karşıya
kalacağız Evet bir spor branşının
başkanlığını yaptım ama aynı zamanda bu
ülkede bu dünyada yaşıyorsak
ormanlarımıza sahip çıkmalıyız
benim her yıldaki maaşım var Çocukların
adına diktiğim ağaçlarım var aile olarak
diktik lerimiz var Sizin var mı mı
Sizlerde lütfen kendinize bir ağaç dikin
isminize bir ağaçtaki ki hiç kimsenin
olmadığı Yani bir hastane bahçesine bir
ağaç dikin bip evinizin bahçesinde kim
Siz bunu yapın E şimdi
Bütün bunlar
orman olacak ki suyla beraber olacak bak
su olmazsa vurman olmaz en büyük
sorunlarımızdan sular olup olmaması
artık küresel bir dönüşüm deyiz Biz
evdeki muslukları mızdaki sulara dahi
dikkat etmeliyiz Biz Türkiye oryantiring
Federasyonu da su ile ilgili bir eğitim
verdik Eğer bir savaş çıkacaksa bundan
sonra su ile ilgili savaş çıkacak bak
neden Doğa Orman ve Su üzerine duruyorum
Biz branşı mızı burada yapıyoruz doğada
ormanda ve
suların olduğu bölgelerde yapıyoruz
Bunlar bizim için olmazsa olmazımız
ormanlarımız yandı spor yaptığımız
haritalarımız gitti bizim haritalarımız
haritaları çizmiştik koşacak yerlerimiz
gitti bizim o ormanın tekrar olması
bizim için çok zor yıllara geçecek
Lütfen şimdi What Now
şimdi harekete geçme zamanı
şimdi harekete geçersek En azından
girecek olan kayıpların önüne geçeriz bu
ne yapmalıyız size ne olacak şimdi
stres atmak istiyorsan çıkacaksın ormana
çıkacaksa Normalde sporunu yapacaksın
Düşünsenize şu ormanın içerisinde de
Kaybolup gideceksin Dört Duvar arasından
çıkıp nefes alacaksın nefesi içine
çekeceksin
bu işleri yaparken Tabii alttan gelen
öğrenciler bunları anlatabilmek lazım
Milli Eğitim üniversiteler Yüksek
Öğrenim Kurumu Biz bunlarla ilgili
birçok çalışma yaptık kitapta
oryantiring yaptık yine iplerden bir
tanesiydi her zaman çıka dışarı
çıkmadığımız zamanlarda bunları Kendi
evlerimizde sanal çevrimiçi yarışmalarda
Bunlar organize ettik biz bunlardan çok
keyif aldık Biz Kadınlar olarak dünyaya
yön verme yönetme bu zamanımız şu an
geldi şimdi bunu yapmalıyız yoksa Bunlar
gerçek bir son değil asmalıyız kadının
gücünü göstermeliyiz tadının gücünü
zamanında
Kurtuluş Savaşı'nın Savaşı'nda ülkemizi
zaten gösterdi atalarımız zaten gösterdi
nene hatunları Halide Edip leri Sabiha
Gökçen ler bizim ilklerimiz ve
örneklerimiz ise biz dünyaya bunları
gösterdik biz bunların torunlarıyız biz
bunların torunları ise biz onlardan daha
çok şey yapmalıyız neden sadece 64
sedasyonda üç tane kadın var
benim canım yanıyor Bence haksızım işim
açığı ve kaldıramıyorum Bunu
neden 81 Gençlik Spor İl müdürlüklerine
81 ilde hiç kadın yok sıfır böyle bir
şey var mı
Biz yapamazmıyız
alasını yaparız o zaman bize verilmesine
beklemeyeceğiz biz ne yapacağız de
isteyeceğiz Biz bunu yaparız diyeceğiz
biz bunu başarabiliriz diyeceğiz işte
What Now Şimdi tam da
harekete geçme zamanı
dünyaya yön verme ülkemize yön verme
zamanı Evet Şimdi Sıra Sizde
Bizler yaptık yapmaya yine devam
edeceğiz ama Haydi kadınlar
bir dünyaya ismimizi bırakma zamanı Evet
hepinizi şimdi
doğanın içerisine ormana bırakıyorum Köz
lerimizi kapatıp derin bir nefes
alıyoruz kendimizi orada Hayal ediyoruz
teşekkür ediyorum saygılar sunuyorum öp